you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum fun guest today I love
this guy I've met him before he's so
humble and sweet and glorious bastards
Freaks and Geeks I mean
he's he's kind of a little Legend he is
he is and he's so smart
I'm just like you know it's just fun to
listen to him and his stories and the
way he sees life yeah you know we'll get
into Sam Levine that's Sam with two M's
because there probably was already a Sam
Levine and sag that's how they do it
I just wanted to give a little shout
outs if you'll kindly listen to them I'd
love you to subscribe if you're
listening to Sam for Sam Levine if you
like the podcast that is if not tell me
to f off that's fine too uh the handles
Ryan uh inside of you Paul on Twitter
inside of your podcast on Instagram
Facebook yeah follow us write a review
or on YouTube as well if you want to
watch it which is always nice but watch
it we have Eclipse Channel but try to
subscribe write a review
um we have the inside of you online
store that's what it's called tons of
cool merch
um from inside of you mugs and and
tumblers we have actually some new
Smallville stuff we have a well we have
a Lex Luthor signed leximus script from
the show
um we have a Lex Luthor signed ship key
the key to the ship
so you're going to want it they're going
to be they're going to be around they're
going to be available they're dope
they're they're like hotcakes I I put
six up they were gone in 20 minutes so
I'm gonna I'm trying to get more so this
guy is supposed to send me a bunch so
keep a look at them not the inside of
you online store also
um sunspin.com go to sunspin.com and get
your new sunspin merch our band has an
album out a CD it will be streaming in
like February uh you could listen to our
last album uh best days it's called Sun
spins the band best days is the name of
the album the new one's coming out but
you can get that on CD at sunspin.com
along with t-shirts uh mugs uh
hats tons of cool [ __ ] calendars what's
the name of this album or is it it's
called Never is what it is never is what
it is
yeah there's a song called that it's uh
it's it's pretty it's a kind of a sad
song I was going through a tough time so
there's a couple of songs that are you
know sounds like a Tom Petty lyric
yeah it does yeah never is what it is
you have to you have to hear the album
but it's really cool a bunch of great
musicians so support the band
sunspin.com follow us whatever what have
you and just a shout out to
um foodonfoot.org helping the homeless
on this
you know dismal year we've had and you
know people are still out there starving
and uh go to go to foodonfoot.org and if
you can help in any way it helps them
tremendously uh also Echoes of Hope for
foster youth it's a beautiful
organization and Ryan I'll be in Vegas
with Tom Welling oh yes to do a uh a
convention Friday Saturday and Sunday
the 13th 14th and 15th of January Vegas
Smallville nights with Tom we do a
two-man event reads scripts from the you
know the old scripts from Smallville you
read with us it's gonna be a blast where
which uh Hotel do you remember I don't
know but they'll you know look on my
Instagram in the next couple weeks
because you'll see it so join me
um and last but not least arm the animal
rescue mission
um you can go on Instagram
and my friend Shiro runs it and they are
rescuing so many animals
uh there's so many animals out there
that are starving or abused or left to
you know die and
she tries to save every friggin animal
I'm like you can't do that you're not
Noah
stop and uh but she she really has a
heart of gold and uh help the
organization tell them uh tell him I
told you to come and also Ronald
McDonald House can't forget that in Los
Angeles love those guys uh that's about
it for the for the holidays we're
getting there we're getting to uh
Christmas Hanukkah Kwanzaa kwanzai
Kwanzaa Kwanzaa why not yeah you know I
mean I [ __ ] everything up yeah uh any
any plans for you you don't want to see
your folks again right don't see my
folks again yeah because yeah you were
talking about that you were saying it's
it's you call it home because it is home
it yeah I didn't grow up there but like
now I can't imagine my parents living
anywhere else they've really ingrained
themselves in the community in a good
way they settled in they settled in
mom's got a garden my dad's got his
bands like they're they're in and Ryan's
also I like that you're you've been in
the last couple of months I've seen like
a shift I don't know if it's the therapy
the better health therapy because I mean
seriously I mean sponsor yeah they are a
sponsor but they're awesome that's the
way they've been with us because they
know everybody out there deals with
anxiety depression and everything in
between and uh you've been doing it but
also
um you're taking a writing class every
week you're really enjoying it you're
starting to do like comedy like oh you
did you had to go last night it was good
it was good I knew it would be good you
were nervous I wasn't because I had done
it in two and a half years but you
killed it yeah I think so I mean I got
enough people invited enough people and
they like they um it was in it was in El
Segundo which is which is not yes uh for
a Wednesday so I mean I got a lot of
money going again
um I mean hopefully that's like a
monthly show
um so but where would they go
they called it uh recession-proof comedy
and so they just invite so there's just
gonna be a um just a comedy night like
the second Wednesday of every month at
The brewport Tap House in El Segundo all
right so you'll you'll let me know a
week ahead of time when you're going to
do it and we'll we'll make if you want
to go out there it's going to be on a
Wednesday in El Segundo so but Ryan's a
little celebrity here I mean he's on
inside of you here you love him the
people folks love you you're on
talkville you know it's like you know
your personality you're getting some you
know some fans some love so they'll come
and love you you'll get a couple
supporters yeah I'm sure Brian
hindenkamp would come see you it's a far
ride for him though I think he lives
pretty far away but you like that I
shouted out your name all right uh
without further Ado uh also I gotta
thank my patrons without you the show
wouldn't exist talkfill wouldn't exist
you keep the show going truly
um I will do this podcast as long as you
know uh the love keeps coming for
patrons patreon.com inside of you to
support the podcast I'll try to send you
a message
um but a lot of tears and fun stuff on
patreon without further Ado let's get in
the wonderful talented
incredible you like that Sam
Sam Levine it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rose
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
dude how are you I'm great man I'm I'm
genuinely great I got married I know you
married Rachel you met her on a game
show ish Schmo down yes the movie trivia
Showdown you let me know when we're
going we're probably already started
aren't we oh yeah yeah that's what Pete
does he just rolls right into it by the
way
start
um that show it was called movie trivia
Showdown the movie trivia Showdown yeah
slow down let me ask me some questions
to see if I would be a movie Enthusiast
without going you know can you I could
ask you a few probably but I mean there
are like super easy softball ones and
then there are like five pointer
very very difficult questions like give
me a give me an easy one start me easy
an easy one would be like
um uh how many uh Terminator films did
James Cameron Direct in the 90s
wow I thought this was easy one that's
correct yeah yeah just the one yeah uh
because for 84 or 91 yep exactly there
you go that's right so that's yeah so
that's like you're like oh you want to
think about it because you don't want to
jump into an answer and go oh my God I
can't believe I forgot that and then
like a super hard one uh would be oh
great no I don't want to do it I don't
wanna I I honestly nothing's even coming
to me because they're all really uh
something give me some they're super com
there you have to read a list of names
to make sure that you're giving the
appropriate information uh there was one
it was like what
um comedy uh uh starring for featuring
Paul Newman John Goodman and Steve
Buscemi uh
from the 90s like it was Paul Newman and
Robert Redford was the category like
what comedy featuring Newman also has
90s comedy featuring new and also has
supporting performances from John
Goodman Steve Buscemi and I'm leaving
stuff out because I don't remember wow
that's the comedy yeah it's comedy was
it a really obscure movie no you've
heard of it but it's not it's not a pool
movie no it's not the Stakeout it is not
the Stakeout wasn't he in that I don't
think Newman's in Stakeout what was it
it's the HUD sucker proxy the HUD sucker
proxy Cohn Brothers movie yes I should
have known that when you said Goodman
Goodman in Buscemi giveaways yeah I like
that your mind thinks the way I do like
when I hear certain actors like I think
that's one of the reasons I was okay at
it was I know like certain directors who
love to work with repeat actors yes like
Henry Gibson is in a movie there's a
very good chance Joe Dante directed it
for example yeah that's good yeah can
you name every now I'm not going to do
this we can't do this I was going to say
can you name every Tarantino movie in
order probably but who cares who cares
everybody's thinking about it right now
right they're thinking about it right
sit down email it into US did you always
have an affinity from movies uh growing
up in television was it something that
was embedded in your kind of it was part
of your DNA from the moment you got out
of mom's womb yes uh and I owe that to
two things one both my parents are uh
cinephiles really both still with us yes
thank God uh so they and my mother's
father uh he too was a cinephile he had
a massive collection of laser discs and
VHS and all the stuff in the in the 80s
and early 90s so love and appreciation
of Cinema was something I was raised
with and then the second thing the real
kicker was uh they allowed me to have a
television in my bedroom with uh
unfettered cable access when I was 11
years watching HBO I'm watching HBO give
me the HBO theme
yeah we could have done the whole thing
I don't think it takes like a minute it
does um but yes uh yeah at HBO Cinemax
wow did you watch dirty stuff on Cinemax
of course I did you were you jerking off
were you watching um goodbye Emmanuel uh
yeah Emmanuel's uh diary or whatever
they call do you remember there was a
song to those movies goodbye Emmanuel I
remember when I was a kid I was watching
I was like it was like goodbye Emmanuel
oh Emmanuel
goodbye Emmanuel I just remember to see
you got to see some boobs I remember
trying to jerk off when I was you know
12 13 years old to real sex and I was
like oh no wait a minute could come back
with the attractive ladies there's this
is a nudist colony thing I don't these
are old dudes why oh no my eyes
um yeah don't if you're if you're me and
12 don't attempt to uh masturbate too
now your your dad was a dentist uh still
is still is a dentist does he still do
your teeth he does and oh he's gonna
love this uh he just relocated to Los
Angeles right after the jerking off he
hears that he's gonna hear about it you
know when I edit this for him right
right uh yeah no he uh he he practices
in Elena really yeah yeah the dentists
do really well
um I think it really depends on a number
of factors
um but primarily believe it or not it
has to do with what type of Dentistry
you want to pursue because uh you know
periodontist endodontist orthodontist
orthodontist now Ortho that's the sweet
sweet money but the catch is all day
every day for your life you're going to
be doing braces and retainers and braces
and retainers right and that's it he
didn't do that no he's a general dentist
so he'll do he gets to do the fun
variety but he doesn't do oral surgery
he does not do oral surgery you go to an
oral surgery oral surgeon for that yeah
interesting yeah did you like going to
the dentist when you're young like it no
but I didn't mind it like other kids
like you hated it it was the worst thing
massive anxiety you know that's horrible
anxiety with it uh Eddie Murphy Oh
that's what I hear okay I know I know
the truth why doesn't he just send it
she should do that now that's a little
bit of inside Hollywood for those who
knows but do you think Dad was more mean
to you and wanted you to feel a little
pain in a sadistic sort of way when you
went in as of just like oh it's gonna no
pain
what 100 do you think he gave it to you
a little bit he honestly he would just
poke around in there with the metal
sharp thing there was nothing medically
necessary about it what were your
influences like growing up to like to be
an actor what movies did you see where
you were like I have to do this
um the first one this goes back to 11
year old or 12 I'm 12 years old now yeah
how old are you 40. I'm 40 yeah 40. so
uh the TV in my bedroom and it's the
middle of the night and A Clockwork
Orange comes on really and I've never
got you into it well that was the movie
that I saw that made me
completely change the way I viewed
movies and entertainment because I'd
never seen anything that grown up I'd
never seen anything that intense that
was the first thing where I went oh [ __ ]
I had no idea movies could be like this
incredibly disturbing and then it's all
I wanted to do was watch I don't say
[ __ ] up movies but like movies that
made me think and movies that made me
think about things differently look at
things differently and I was I rewatched
that movie so many times and uh shortly
thereafter Reservoir Dogs
um and uh like those probably those two
movies had a dream tremendous impact
what were your parents thinking when you
were watching these kind of movies were
they concerned at all were they uh you
know what what is he doing now what's he
gonna do with his life I don't think I
was you're in Illinois right no Jersey
born in Chicago born in Chicago because
I was born I was born in New York and I
grew up in Indiana you were born in
Chicago and went raised outside of New
York yeah right right
um and uh no they I I don't know that my
mother knew that I was watching these
terrible things my dad probably did
because I would talk to him about it and
be like you know what I watched last
night it was A Clockwork Orange you go
oh I saw that at the Ziegfeld theater in
1971 I'm like all right this isn't about
you
um but uh yeah no they they they knew
and then also by the time I was 12 I was
doing stand-up comedy
that started at bar mitzvahs when I was
11 and 12. what kind of jokes are you
telling a kid's bar mitzvahs remember
folks you're 13 when you have a bar
mitzvah yeah what you would you do bot
Mitzvahs or just stick to the barman's
bar and but benign
okay that's the plural is that yeah okay
good
um uh the uh the jokes I would do were
probably five percent my own which were
not terribly funny but then 95 the grade
A material of one uh Richard Jenny may
he rest in peace do you remember Richard
Jenny no oh he was magnificent he was
one of the hardest working comics in
Show Business in the 80s and 90s uh and
he had a number of HBO Comedy hours and
Showtime specials
um he had a big one in 1993 that was
eye-opening for me called platypus man
uh and uh he he was just absolutely
brilliant and he had so many bits that I
memorized word for word give me one you
want the whole thing I just want a nice
come on I don't well he's gotta okay
here's what he did from a later comedy
special he said um he was talking about
first dates and he said I don't know why
men have the nerve to wear a sport
jacket on the first date you lying son
of a [ __ ] like this is who you are you
know what a man should be wearing on the
first date a top hat a white tie and a
cane because he's just doing the same
old song and dance you know I really
like kids I don't care much for sports I
love scented candles and I don't believe
in divorce tell me more about your cat
I'm hanging on every word there you go
that's wow you do this why thank you uh
I wouldn't do that I don't think he'd
written that yeah yeah it was a little
older steal it yet right right right but
jokes of that ilk so yeah I was doing
goofy stuff like that and uh it was just
what'd you do in front of your parents
the jokes oh sure and they thought you
were hilarious yeah own bar mitzvah too
he said you started just oh so you had
this innate sort of confidence as a
young boy you could see that when you
start seeing your work like early on
even like Freaks and Geeks you can see
that that maturity that kind of like wow
this guy's an actor I don't know about
maturity but that that misappropriated
confidence right like looking back there
was a large amount of naivete right that
it's based out of but looking back so
confident no it's because I didn't know
what the hell was going on were you
popular in high school oh God no not at
all not even never never got the girls
no no no no no no really no no no very
unpopular
yeah what would they were you picked on
uh from time to time what would they do
uh well I mean things were written on my
locker like why ah don't say Jew bastard
no no I only had one or two uh uh
anti-semitic things screamed at me and
in my young life uh mostly by strangers
um what did they write oh somebody wrote
Sam is whack and whack and I was so
uncool I literally had to ask us like I
don't know is whack good or bad
did you ever did you ever like because I
was picked on a little bit and I I know
what that's like I wasn't popular but
did you ever go home and sort of like
were you upset about it did you cry were
you sit in your room and say oh did you
have friends or did you not worry about
it too much I did have friends
um and I didn't worry about it because
uh uh I mean when I was really young I
probably no I definitely worried about
it it made me sad and all that uh but I
had this Epiphany I remember I was
walking home from school one day uh I I
was maybe about 12 or 13 years old and I
was starting to do stand up and feeling
like I had a very good idea of what I
wanted to do with my adult life
and I remember I was walking up this
hill lived up this hill I was walking up
this hill and I like stopped and I had
this absolute Epiphany where I was like
oh wait a minute I'm only in school with
these idiots for like four or five more
years and then I'm gonna go have my own
life and I'm gonna go and I'm do cool
great things I'm gonna be on stage doing
stuff I want to do what perspective this
matters at all I just gotta get through
the next five years fine [ __ ] them I
don't care see the difference between
you and me
is I was thinking how do I get through
tomorrow sure how do I possibly get
through the next four years yeah it was
always and that carried on yeah with me
how do I get through this thing I'm
doing instead of trying to make the best
of it and enjoy it it's just stress
anxiety how do I you know but that is a
very mature way of thinking thank you I
don't I don't know I have no good
explanation for why I had that thought
uh but it I remember it I remember it
vividly and I just remember that was a
defining moment for me sort of just
being able to handle anything socially
that High School threw at me were you
able to do people call you once you got
famous or or like when you went back
home the people that you were like you
were never nice to me did they because
they come out of the woodwork all right
they happened with me sure oh no I have
uh apparently 30 or 40 best friends from
high school that I misremember how close
we were and how frequently they asked me
to hang out it's so true I'm like do you
remember you never him
so what do you do how do you I just I'm
I guess I'm too good-natured I just sort
of go hey oh yeah how are you I just go
with it sure whatever I'm not I just go
with it too and I mean I I am on social
media and so a lot of them have you know
reconnected with me there and um at
first I was like I mean I know what
happened should I just
ignore this person on social media I'm
like no no I I think I want them to know
how I'm doing kill them and I'd like to
know how they're doing did you were did
you really want to know how they're
doing some of them
some of them yeah
yeah because people do change they
absolutely do unless you're a child who
kills animals and things they usually do
then they all they grow up to be Jeffrey
Dahmer sure so you know you're Tom
Welling oh no how dare you how would you
but um weird shot
inside of you is sponsored by better
help you know this holiday season do
something for a special person in your
life you
give yourself a gift to raise your
spirits and not just for the day look
the holiday can be a really tough time
for all of us between managing family
Dynamics racing from thing to thing
braving the cold and dark weather it's
it's normal to feel down having someone
to talk about how you're feeling and
what you can do about it is truly truly
a gift I've been doing therapy for years
it's important part of my life it has
become a part of my life it's become a
part of Ryan's life and I don't know
what I'd do without it and if you're
just getting started better help is the
perfect platform that's why they've been
a sponsor for a while because they
taught they see how we talk about mental
health and mental health affects
everybody including celebrities and
directors and it just it's it's
Universal it's it's a human thing and uh
we need people to talk to someone on the
outside that knows how to deal with
these things and helps us navigate
through life so I I strongly recommend
better help and so many people so many
patrons and listeners have emailed me
messaged me about how much better help
helps them
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
so did you ever ever have
become friends with someone from high
school that you weren't friends with in
high school has that ever happened no
that's never happened also I I think one
of the things I remember I was having a
really hard time in like fifth grade and
I remember asking my mom
uh because you know the only thing when
you're fifth grade's your friends in
your life and that's your whole world
and I remember asking my mom I'm like
are you are you still friends with any
of the people you went to school with
she's like no I was like really not high
school or college or anything she goes I
have like two friends from college that
I keep in touch with but I know no one
from my life before that you know and
yeah and I remember having that hit me
and like really trying to wrap my head
around like oh
lit many years from now I won't know
these people and I mean if In fairness
to her social media the internet was not
yet a thing right
um because then it would be impossible
to get be in touch it would be
impossible it would be then forget it
they'd have no way yeah that's true
that's true
um but even with that uh it's yeah I
don't I know them I know they're out
there every now and then I'll you know
chime in with one of them online or
something but by and large no that's
that is a part of my distant past it was
really weird I was in New York and I was
doing sketch comedy for Conan O'Brien
and when he was you know nobody was
watching no one was watching I was
watching Michael you were I was you are
but I was the Amsterdam kids the two
kids that were misinformed about
Amsterdam's liberal social policies I
was a recurring sketch comedy guy I did
like Eight Episodes and it was huge for
me I was on TV you know some people saw
me
and I got a phone call from this guy
that I went to high school with who I I
hung out with every once in a while and
I liked him I remember liking him I go I
like this guy we went cruising you know
things like that he was more popular
than I am he got girls I didn't hang out
with his crew but he would invite me
sometimes and I got a message and it
goes Rosenbaum
dude it's Kent brennaman
I'm watching TV
and you come on the screen
dude that's so cool man I'd love to
catch up it's been forever man congrats
gave me his number
and I called him yeah and I was like and
we talked and then I would go I had no
other reason to go home and my my mom
was still there
but I didn't go home very often I didn't
really hang out with anybody for a while
and I went home and all these people
came out of the woodwork that can't
organize like to hang out wow and a lot
of them I was like I remember you I went
to high school with and you were popular
and I but I don't I didn't hang out with
these guys yeah so they're all hanging
around and you know year after year I'd
go home for whatever and it was kind of
like there was a couple of people that I
I still keep in touch with no is all
this pretty Smallville pretty Smallville
wow yeah and so yeah it was just it was
odd and you go back and this was like
only like five years after you know High
School ended oh yeah and so I would see
these guys at home and I I'd be like you
know and
they were so nice to me sure because I
was on TV sure and I just I just I I
reciprocated I was like Hey and you know
we were friendly and it was just it was
just really odd A lot of times yes no a
similar thing happened to me when I was
uh 19 I was only two years out of high
school and I had uh was in a feature
film Not Another Teen Movie and it was
released uh in December of that year so
I was back home in Jersey seeing family
for the holidays and the movie was still
in theaters and so then you know words
spread oh Sam's here Sam's oh does he
want to go see his movie with us and the
same thing people I did I went to go see
a movie I was in with a group of people
I went to high school with many of whom
I hadn't spoken more than five sentences
to over the entirety of high school and
uh we came out of the movie and people
oh that's great oh that's great what was
what was Cousin Eddie like because Randy
Quaid is in the movie of course uh and
then the one girl who I'd had a huge
crush on my whole school life
she like looks me dead in there she's
like it was weird seeing you in a movie
weird well bye and I was like okay I
think we're done here wow was it
uncomfortable no it was just surreal and
you know did you feel like the man for a
second for a split second until everyone
was just like all right well let's uh
move on let's not laud him too much we
didn't like him when we were students
with him let's not pretend we do now but
what's weird is now that we're all
adults I get the most lovely messages
sometimes
um mostly about how their kids have seen
me in some of the stuff that I do more
that's geared towards young people right
um which is delightful what made you get
into acting was it your love for Cinema
and then doing the bar mitzers and the
stand-up and that kind of gave you the
confidence to start doing plays in high
school it started with stand up
um and uh from there I got a manager in
New York and he was the one who wanted
me to be submitted uh on auditions right
and I mean in addition to that I was
doing school plays and stuff like that
uh not really too many school plays
mostly you were a late bloomer though
aren't you because I was a friend but I
was a really late bloomer I didn't start
puberty I think to my junior year in
high school yeah I didn't have a armpit
here until probably I was 16. yeah no I
didn't hit puberty until I was about 28.
if memory sir perfect perfect yeah yeah
no it took forever
but you're a tall handsome laugh and
look at this hairy chest now oh buddy
yeah do you have oh juice
the uh yeah we can pair that later we'll
put that we'll put that on the patreon
yeah um the uh uh the the the the
problem with me was I was I was a short
short stuff as they would say hey short
stuff
um were you did you reach your maximum
height in high school no I I was
probably about five one when I was a
freshman and by the time I finished high
school I was maybe five three or five
four I I think I hit my maximum height
when I was 18. were your parents short
uh not really I am short uh primarily
because I was a very sick kid where are
you very sick I was in the hospital all
this one
um really bad asthma cardiovascular
issues some heart stuff bad news uh did
you almost die and debatable
um there was there was a couple times I
got really sick like I had viral
pneumonia that had me in the hospital
for like three weeks once and they were
just like we don't know what to do
nothing's making them better
um and uh so the problem was this is the
80s early 90s and back then the thing
was okay prednisone just all the
prednisone all the time and that's all
well and good but the problem is as
they've learned if you give that much
prednisone to a young person it can
really stunt their growth
um so that's what that's pretty much
what did it because I I have a brother
he's just over six feet tall
um and you know my dad he's shrinking
now but at his full adulthood he was
probably five ten five eleven right
um you know my mother was normal height
but there's no reason I should have been
that tiny a kid
yeah other than the drugs makes sense I
I remember I was five foot two and a
half when I graduated high school and I
grew somehow I grew in the next year and
a half we were like nine inches wow the
girls were always like oh you're so cute
Rosy cute little Rosie I was never a guy
that was gonna get the girls I never got
the girls ever not at that age
College yeah until College it started
happening a little bit Yeah but um so I
know I do know what that feels like but
like was that really hard on you were
you like always did you let it go you're
like I'm I'm short this is the way it's
gonna be I yes because in high school it
was a non-starter uh it was never gonna
happen for me with any of the girls in
my high school and I knew that and I did
not attempt uh but then luckily I mean
I was on Freaks and Geeks you know
immediately after that uh immediately
after high school immediately after like
done with high school
in uh June starting Freaks and Geeks
July
unbelievable yeah
um and so
after that I was like yeah you know it's
my understanding that uh people on
television have an easier go at this and
they like me I'm good I'm getting cast
what was that audition process I'm sure
you've talked about this was it
something you auditioned for repeatedly
uh not repeatedly like I've I've
repeatedly auditioned for things since
then no I went in and read uh just for
Allison Jones The Great casting director
Emmy award-winning for her work on
Freaks and Geeks by the way yeah uh uh
uh casting director Allison Jones so
first I went and I read for her and uh I
got the audition like any other I think
it was the very first actual pilot
audition I'd ever been set up with right
and that was only because Judd aptown
Paul feig were specifically looking for
unpolished non-like known TV film actors
like they they didn't want if you had a
crazy resume they were not interested
wow they wanted young people that looked
like real Unknown People yeah so that's
impossibly how I got the call to go
audition for this and originally I read
for the role that John Daly uh played uh
Sam Weir right and so it says in the
breakdown it's like oh he's nerdy he's
undersized uh he likes doing impressions
with his friends they talk about comedy
all the time I'm like well that's me
um so I I hope this goes well and uh God
bless her my mother was like oh it says
he does Impressions you should do your
impressions and at the time I had again
I was doing stand-up and I used to do a
truly terrible impression of William
Shatner which is terrible terrible like
it was not a good Improvement thing yeah
it wasn't even that good it wasn't even
that good it was mostly uh it was that
it was just that that's good though it
was good so
so I was like yeah all right fine so
when I go into the audition
um they always ask me do you have any
questions and I say yeah it says he does
uh Impressions I actually do a William
Shatner impression uh could I do that as
part of the audition and they're like uh
yeah we'll do it at the end okay great
so then I read the role of Sam Weir not
particularly well and then literally I
turned uh casting her like okay go ahead
and then I launch into my crappy Shatner
impression which was something directly
from my ACT I did him on Rescue 9-1-1
remember he used to host yeah tonight at
all rest good on why
that's right anyway so so did you think
this was this didn't go well I no I was
like yeah it went fine but I've at that
point I had hundreds of auditions I and
you weren't getting tons no you go in
you do it you move on with your life and
um and I felt pretty good about it and
then
um like a day later they called and uh
like hey they want to read you for
producers
and I said oh great
um so that's a different character well
here's what happened okay so the real
story is uh Judd Apatow was looking at
the tapes and he saw that and my read of
the scene was not very good but he got
such a kick out of my bad Shatner that
he said oh you know what put that kid on
the Callback list if nothing else Paul
feig is coming in to do the first round
of callbacks that'll give him a good
laugh
like just have this kid do a show you
found out through just John and Paul
they both told me that story yeah
they're like no you only wound up on
that list because I wanted to make Paul
laugh that's it and so Paul was the one
who I went to do my callback for and
when I went in and I read for Sam Weir
again and then I did my chatner and then
Paul was like that's great that's great
you know what can I give you a different
character to read I was like yeah so
then he gives me Neil Schreiber and I
take that outside and I work on it in
the waiting room for 20 minutes and they
were like you know whenever you're ready
just let us know
and so I looked at it I was like I feel
like I could do this too and then like
three kids later I go back in and I do
that for Paul and he was really into it
he was like no no let's try it this way
try it this way try it this way and so
and you were giving him what he wanted I
hope so I think so he did obviously um
and she was like okay great okay thanks
so much and I leave and then an hour
later they call again they're like okay
they want to see you again tomorrow
I was like okay great and so now I go in
and so now I'm reading for Paul and Judd
Apatow and Jay kazden the director of
the pilot and I walk in and Judd
literally says all right Levine warm us
up with some Shatner
and so I start with the audition this
time or the the impression and and then
we start doing Neil schweiber and same
thing we're working on it we're doing
this they give me an extra scene uh and
we just we're having goofy fun with it
were you nervous uh or just fun nervous
I was fun nervous I mean I think the
fact that I done stand up at that point
for so many years on stage in New York
like I didn't get the typical stage
fright stuff like and then also again
uh unnecessary confidence there's no
reason I should have been that confident
it was borderline arrogance right and I
was like I could I could do this I know
what they want
[ __ ] idiot who called you did your
manager call you when you got it so well
first they called me and that later that
night hey they want to network test you
oh you gotta find another one you gotta
fly to L.A oh boy yeah so the good thing
here though was and this is the only
time in my career it's ever happened boy
that really screwed me this being my
first job Judd told DreamWorks it was
the studio I'm not Studio testing any of
these kids I'm not gonna make him do it
twice I'm telling you who I want you
approve them I'm taking them to network
and DreamWorks said okay so you skipped
it so we did not have to do the studio
test just the network test right and uh
yeah so it was at the old NBC Studios in
Burbank yeah
um and we do a work session and at the
work session this is a lot for a TV show
or a lot of to go through I'm you know
what this is yeah I mean I've done it
but I've never I mean I guess I have I
remember the community I I it was just
between me and Joel McHale and we kept
going in and out and then and uh yeah I
remember going he's gonna get it he's
the part I'm not mature enough he's
gonna get and he got him and remember
we've talked about that before when he
was on the podcast uh but go ahead so so
yeah so we're doing a little work
session with all the actors and uh and
once again uh Judd has me do you know
whatever goofy Impressions and other
stuff like he wanted me to warm up our
own room and then when I went into the
big room with all the suits there's 30
suits in there uncomfortable it's it
would be but I was the first one to walk
in that day and he goes hey is everybody
Sam Levine everybody starts applauding
and then I completely stole a line from
Richard Jenny which worked great by the
way for years of auditions everybody
applauds when you walk into a test
because they want to make you feel at
ease and I was like whoa whoa no that's
premature what if I suck then we'll all
be embarrassed right come on let's not
do this to each other
um and they laugh and they laughed and
then uh Judd was like oh I mean warm up
the warm up the suits with uh some
Shatner or something
so this is like the fifth time he's
asked me to do it on cue and I'm always
happy to oblige uh so I did it and it
got huge laughs and I guess it put the
room at ease or whatever and then we
launched into the scene and we did the
scene and and I you know I even think he
was like uh well let's do the second
half of it one more time so we did the
second half one more time okay thanks
and then I leave and then they bring me
and uh John Daly and Martin Starr in
various groups to read with each other
mix and match and there was only one
other kid reading for Neil and he looked
significantly younger than me and I mean
I know I had a baby face this kid looked
10 or 11 years old right
um and my thinking and I don't know who
that kid is in my apologies but my
thinking was they wanted me Judd and
Company wanted me and so rather than
only read me they brought in another kid
who was like good enough
but it's it's one of those mental things
that I've definitely seen producers do
where they bring in somebody give this
guy so they'll think this guy's
substantially better exactly he's better
for the part he's better for the part
here of the choices who do you like uh
so I I think that's what happened and
then after the test me and my mother and
Martin and his mother uh grabbed lunch
at the NBC commissary and then we left
and uh I was staying at the Hilton
Universal Hilton and uh taking the
elevator upstairs walking back to the
room and as I'm walking to the room I
can hear the phone ringing inside the
hotel room and I like open the key and I
run in and I answer the phone and it's
my manager's like you got it
and that was it that's why I got the
part wow
I always ask this question yeah Ryan
knows it but this is your first TV show
this is you're one of the leads did they
pay you a lot no comparatively speaking
what what did someone back in
1999 it was 99 get paid to be a an actor
of your caliber of your staff which was
none which was none exactly zero I'm
gonna guess
you probably got paid
twenty five thousand dollars
wow 15
000. look it's lower than that and let
do you really wanna yeah that's from the
past sure they gave me 10 grand 10 grand
an episode
but I was only guaranteed 7 out of
Thirteen I wound up being in all of them
uh and that was because Scott sassa the
then Network president saw a script that
the I was not in and I don't know if he
had it if he liked me as an actor if he
liked what he saw what I did or whatever
but I remember getting that script at
home looking through it and going oh
Neil's not in this one
um and I remember telling my mother she
was like oh that's fine you have a week
off I was like Mom if I'm not in it I
don't get paid
oh and I just thought okay fine I got a
week off and then like two days later
they sent me a new draft and I was in it
and I found out Scott sassa the
president of NBC said all the Geeks are
in it every episode
who do you think I paid the most oh got
to have been Linda or Siegel or Franco
one of those three got paid substantly
more yeah they were they were probably
making closer to to 20 to 25 or whatever
right right because they some of them
had real credits
um were you were you friend friendly or
just would you are you still friendly
with who would you say are your closest
friends out of that group now I'm
definitely closest with John he and I
have always been tight John Daly John
Daly um because you guys were best
friends in the show yeah yeah
um and and he was three he's like three
years younger than I am so you know
Martin and I and and Seth were all 17
John's 14. this was tough that's a
that's a sizable age difference at that
age uh but then the show ended and like
I just liked John so John was the only
one you really hung out with immediately
after the show he's the only one I saw
regularly socially yeah were there any
crushes or any love making or anything
behind the scenes that were going on
there were plenty of crushes uh did you
have a crush oh everybody we all had
crushes but did anybody hook up
yes I mean I famously I think oh she's
Linda and Jason right right right of
course that's because the movie uh right
uh Forgetting Sarah Sarah Marshall right
uh and uh but no I never
had any dalliances with any of the were
they broken up by the way uh did they
break up during the Run show no no they
got together together it worked really
hard to keep it to hide it yeah right uh
and they did like it wasn't until long
after the show was over they were like
hey did you know and something like I
knew yeah the [ __ ] you did
um
but no they they they did not we we no
one caught on well were you stunned
because it was such a great show I mean
I everybody I know just loved that show
it just makes no sense I talked to Judd
he was on the podcast
and uh
when that show got canceled it had to be
I mean how upset were you it was one of
the worst days of my life were you just
shocked how could this happen
um yeah the same day that I heard the
show was canceled uh I I was working a
different job and my car died uh on the
day and I was like oh how can things get
any worse and then uh I've got the phone
call that the show had been canceled
and I thought this is terrible and then
who called you
um who did call me actually uh
Josh Weinstein uh who's one of our
writers and producers was the one who
let me know did you think it was coming
did you know we all knew it was coming
but we were you know optimistic
delusional whatever we we I didn't want
it to be
going that way
um but uh yeah so Josh actually didn't
call me he picked me up because my car
had was no longer working and so he was
driving me to the garage and that's when
he told me uh oh the show's been
canceled and oh truly the worst news of
the day Paul feig's mom died we all knew
Paul's mom
we loved Paul's mom she was on set all
the time so his show gets canceled and
his mom dies on the same day I think
within a day within a day or so yeah
um and your car breaks down yeah and I
mean that's that's why I start with that
yeah start with that work your way to
the import really important things
um did you cry no you didn't cry when
you got canceled no
boy that's it that phrase takes on new
meaning now doesn't it
just seems like it like it was like holy
[ __ ] it was too good to be true you're
at such a young age or right at high
school you get on this show it's like
the critics loved it oh yeah never a bad
review not one
um I didn't cry I was mentally prepared
for it and also as an actor
uh dealing with rejection dealing with
bad words you have to learn you gotta I
mean I learned instant rejection when I
started doing stand-up when I was a
teenager yeah you know like I tell those
stories and I had some great shows but
mostly bad ones right
um yeah I was not great at it uh I I had
the energy for it I enjoyed doing it but
like if you want to be a great stand-up
you've got to write new material every
day you've got to be trying out new
material five times a week uh and I
never had the
I never the the drive or the patients to
do that sure so I I did my little jokey
jokes and I had fun and you know I'd
write new stuff from time to time but I
bombed a lot because I just I would get
lazy and I would see if I could expand
on existing bits or uh I would take out
the flimsiest of premises hoping it
would connect with people and then I'll
just Riff on it never panned out right
um so yes but the point is I was very
familiar with rejection and bad news
well you were I mean you've heard this
but you're brilliant on that show you're
brilliant you're brilliant you watched
that show right but you delivered you
guys all delivered the characters are
very specific very different very
defined I felt like I was there I felt
like I lived in the neighborhood it was
really a wonderful piece did you think
after Freaks and Geeks was there a lull
or did you just start working because I
see your resume like Ed Spin City just
shoot me Steve Harvey Boston Public
Undeclared What I Like About You 70s
Show Family Guy kind of a modern family
with Hot American Summer all right all
right five over I mean Veronica Mars I
mean you work I thank you however is
there a lull I thought there was going
to be that was my great fear was the
show would end and I wouldn't work
anymore uh but the show ended and I I
did have that Panic thought so I took
the first job offered to me which was
actually a writing job on a game show on
the USA Network called strip poker
strip poke I think I remember that it's
what it sounds like and you were a
writer I wrote yes I wrote dumb jokes
and questions jokey questions for a show
or attractive young co-eds took off
their clothes and it probably didn't pay
much uh it paid 750 a week
and you did it I took that job you took
it whatever happens I'm done whatever
job comes I needed a job I wanted to
stay in La my main job was done I needed
some sort of job are you living alone in
L.A uh yes I am I kicked my mother out
two days after I turned 18. you kicked
her out I was like I'm good
have fun go back to New Jersey
and you're riding on this show I know
people saying God you're great on that
show and no no no nobody saw it at the
time back then no one became a cult
later it didn't become anything until
years down the road uh like the next
fall they had it on uh the Fox Family
Channel uh which doesn't exist anymore
uh they were airing it and then what
really brought it into the public
Consciousness was in the beginning of
2004 they released it on DVD
you know we'd hoped for yeah as a TV
show on do you still see residuals from
that show sure you want to talk about
money on the residuals I don't know what
I get what I get about 38 cents per
episode
and I get those checks I think three
times a year so I'll get there's 18
episodes 18 times a year I'll get 18
checks 38 cents 44 cents ooh a dollar
and one cent I must have been in that
episode guys he's not [ __ ] I'm not
I've had a check written to me for .01
oh I have a collection of those those
are beautiful I still have them I kept
them there is the the True Unicorn of
the residual world is the 0.00
how did that get written it's because
the fractional after the second zero on
the whatever generated you know thing
generating those checks it exists so it
automatically prints the check right but
even though the first two digits are two
zeros it doesn't catch that
so I'm waiting for that Unicorn it's
coming I remember when Inglorious
Bastards was sent to my house
and I read for it but I don't even
remember what I read for
and I was you know it was misspelled you
know yeah and thinking next turn I'll
never be in a Tarantino movie he'll
never cast me one time he saw me at a
bowling alley goes [ __ ] Lex Luthor
and I go [ __ ] Quentin Tarantino yeah
and we had a moment that was it and I
was like hey
and I was hoping that someday I'd be in
a Tarantino phone yeah and you got to do
that you're one of the one of the few
yeah that got to be was it something he
sought at like he went after you I went
in and read like everyone else you did
read but I knew him not well at all we'd
met on a couple of occasions years prior
because I sought him out
so I had heard from Judd that uh before
the DVDs came out he had sent Tarantino
Freaks and Geeks on VHS
and uh I so he I knew he watched them
and according to Judd he liked them and
so this is now 2003 and Jimmy came alive
used to be live back in those days I
remember I don't know if I remember he
used to have guest hosts who would sit
with him for the week sure and uh
Quentin was one of them
and so I knew Jimmy I knew people at the
show and so that was a door that I had
opened to me anytime I wanted I could
just go you called and Jamie and asked
him uh I don't think I called Jimmy I
feel like I called Daniel
uh maybe Daniel or kellison right Daniel
kellison or maybe Ken Crosby any of but
you got on I got I got there I went
backstage and you want a guest I was not
a guest he just wanted to go and hang
out oh just want to hang out in the
green room so that I could because I
knew it would be for you to bring a
poster to get autographs no I was coming
as a attempting to come as a colleague
right right okay okay so you're there
and so I was there and I see Clinton I'm
like hey Quinn he's like hey what's up
freak sing because I think Judd sent you
the VHS he goes oh oh yeah oh my God
what a great show that was Oh What a
terrific show oh yeah yeah let's talk
let's talk and so we went out and did
the show and then after the show ends
we're all hanging in Jimmy's dressing
room
uh which was like the VIP area of the
green room and so I'm just sitting on
the couch in Jimmy's dressing room
talking to Quentin and we're talking
about Freaks and Geeks we're talking
about Kill Bill we're talking about
Regis Philbin for hours sure I as you do
uh like we're talking talking and now
time is going on and like people are
leaving and they're leaving and Jimmy's
gone and I didn't realize it's now just
the two of us sitting in this green room
we did not realize the main green room
area everyone's gone
and so it's been like 90 plus minutes
you're hanging out with Quentin
Tarantino for 90 minutes yes and so then
a security guy walks in and he's like I
hate to be a jerk but uh we kind of want
to go home
and you guys are the last two here so
and it's like oh [ __ ] I had no idea I
was like yeah me neither sorry and
that's when we walked out and realized
no one was there
and so like we walk and his car is I
mean one step outside of the exit from
the building right uh you know there's
fans screaming from or whatever and like
we get outside and he goes oh man it was
really great talking with you I really
like to work together someday I'm like
yeah that'd be all right
let me think about I'll get back to you
I was like yeah that'd be great
uh that was it though and that was you
didn't bring up anything there was
nothing to bring up he was promoting
Kill Bill all right you know and so then
it was in the summer of 2008 That Kill
Bill or excuse me uh bastards the script
was floating around town yes and
everyone went oh and it leaked and oh
you can read it and it's that and he's
looking for he's looking for actors he
needs to make these bastards and so I
called my people and I was like I'd
already read the script you guys got to
get me in there if you fail to get me an
audition for this I am not staying with
this company like not a chance
make this happen get me in that room and
they did and I went in and I read I met
with them and when he was just doing
generals
start just general meetings did not want
people to read just wanted you to come
in say hello shoot the [ __ ] he wanted to
get a Vibe for who you were
which is Bonkers uh but I did and I had
to like bring a DVD with like one
serious scene one funny scene from my
you know reel or whatever and so I had
that ready to go and I go in there and
God bless them I walk in and I was like
hey what's up Sam man good to see you
how you been it's been like four years
since I've seen him last right but like
nothing like no time had passed and we
immediately fell back into that uh
casual fun conversation that we'd had
years earlier
and we talked for like 20 or 30 minutes
and this is on a Friday and he's like
okay okay you know what I want you to
come back on Monday and and read read
for uhudovic and I was like okay he's
like yeah just read read the script
hands me the script read the script and
just you know prepare yudovic
there's like many scenes so I went home
and memorized every udovic scene over
the weekend over the weekend and just
had it down down and so I went in on
Monday and we read udovic for 10 minutes
and they said hers and then he was like
no no donowitz donowitz and then he has
me read donowitz
um to come back memorize and come back
no uh cold and uh so I looked at it for
a few minutes and then I went in and did
it and it's a donowitz scene that's not
in the movie by the way you probably
read for donovitz if I had to guess uh
and it's a scene that was shot but
someday God willing we'll all see it's
donowitz and an old Jewish lady played
by Cloris Leachman and it's him in
Boston before he ships off to war and
he's going that bat that he's got that's
got all the signatures on it those are
the names of the people from his Boston
Neighborhood are we still over in uh
Europe and had family in Boston he said
write write their names down here and
I'll go either find them or get
Vengeance for him
wow and so it's that scene it's [ __ ]
intense right
um and here's my favorite thing about
auditioning for Quentin now most every
other audition you go and the director's
sitting there watching you
and you're reading with you know someone
else casting assistant maybe another
actor when you read for Quentin you read
with Quentin
he is in your scene
he's off book
and he's right up in your face
and he wants to feel how in the scene
you are how what he's getting off of you
if he were acting is it intimidating
wildly
yeah and I was like [ __ ] put up or
shut up like this is it this is what the
man wants I'm gonna give him everything
I held nothing back
uh and we did it many many times we did
YouTubers stuff a bunch we did the
dominant stuff a bunch and I'm in there
for easily a half hour and he's going to
be like all right all right all right
that was great this guy I gotta think I
gotta think but thank you so much and
then I leave
and I hear nothing for two weeks and I'm
losing my mind
because it's a Tarantino movie it's a
role in a Tarantino movie like the the
Pinnacle for me and uh I was like nope
that's it I'm freaking out I gotta go I
can't do this I got on a plane flew to
Chicago bought tickets to see the Cubs
at a home stand that's my happy place
that's how I would deal with something
that stressful and it was while I was in
Chicago that's when I got the call
they're offering you the role I was like
oh yudovic donovitz no hershberg
I'd even read for that
I don't care I'll I'll take a guy
carrying a spear through the background
of one scene it it's like that
Stormtrooper in Star Wars did did uh
Tarantino call you before you started
filming or no no he just showed up on
set did you have any kind of uh boot
camp kind of thing oh yeah yeah we had
two full weeks of was it hell no it
wasn't a proper boot camp like the
Private Ryan guys right right it was not
that it was rehearsal time and uh
weapons training he wanted us to be very
uh Adept with the knives for the
scalping and with all the guns because
all of them were like antique German
guns right that we were using and he was
like look sometimes I I'll be doing a
scene and I'll realize I want you to
have the the machine gun instead of the
rifle and I need you to know how to be
able to use it so familiarize yourself
with everything
um
and and we did so do you remember the
first day of filming uh-huh do you
remember not being able to comprehend
what's going on
um
no I could comprehend what was going on
it was just incredibly cool like it was
you know it was certainly the most uh
well-funded film set I'd ever been on at
that point uh which was lovely and uh
yeah no I remember like the first day we
drove way the hell out to that so the
ditch where you see the kind of the the
big opening bastard scene yep where
bratchman dies and and the whole thing
um that's the first thing we shot
and we were there for six or seven days
and like I remember we had to drive way
the hell out there and we get there and
I'm seeing everything and okay and
here's the tent where you go and we're
gonna bloody up your hands and get them
disgusting and then you go to that next
tent and you'll work with the props guys
and we'll figure out which blade you're
gonna get and which gun you're gonna
have on you and
you know and then head over to set and
we're gonna start blocking and Quentin's
gonna rehearse a couple times and like
we rehearsed for like an hour
before they even set up cameras
I I know that regular people go oh cool
you and I know that's [ __ ] crazy
never happens that's crazy because
they're yeah everyone back you film it
they're paying everyone
through the nose to to be there
and he just gets to take the time he
wants as many takes as he wants many
days as he needs I mean we had two full
weeks of rehearsal so that means all the
actors are being paid to be there and
not a frame of film and how long were
you there I was there from
September all told it was about four
months I think maybe four and a half
well what's it like I mean when when is
he shouting things at you to say and do
things depending on the scene yes Sam
Sam just say this turn your head and do
that yes and then put your gun down
scream yeah
open your eyes yes all that [ __ ] all of
that [ __ ] not all of the time some of
the time depending on the scene the
setup the angle whatever uh but he so
the bastards
um largely were comedic actors you got
me BJ Novak Paul rust
so he wanted comedians in those roles to
play it serious but he wanted to find
the humor
and so I think that's why he hired us
right uh and so he encouraged
improvisation and you improvised yeah
anything you improvised that's in the
movie now that you remember no
no no but you improvised them we did it
you did it we did it yeah was did you
let was he
someone who
can be really Intense or was he was he
always full of energy and positivity or
was did you ever see him stress and
really have anxiety and and you know
like oh my God I definitely saw him
stress uh and I I don't know how else to
say it completely justifiably right you
know playing things going on a million
things going on and there was one scene
and
there was a prop that needed to be reset
in between takes and we did the first
scene and the prop breaks which it's
supposed to do and then uh we're waiting
we're we're gonna you know okay we're
gonna go again we're waiting we're
waiting we're waiting five minutes ten
minutes and then from the next room I
hear are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh god what happened apparently there
was miscommunication or whatever and the
props guys were like it's going to take
40 minutes to set that up again
it's like you think I have 40 minutes
between takes so he
was justified I was like no I'd be
pretty angry too that is a colossal did
they get it on the next thing though he
was like I remember him saying something
like you have 10 minutes to get that set
up and they did we did it on the next
take and whatever whatever they did
after that they fixed it I don't know if
they were they swapped out a different
prop for the thing they needed or what
have you but it was that was personally
the like the angriest and most dressed I
saw him get but otherwise totally
infectious good spirits he does this
thing he's famous for it if you've ever
seen any behind the scenes footage
he's not David Fincher level with
multiple takes but sometimes we will do
a lot of takes on the same setup again
and again and again and you can feel
people will start to get exhausted and
so you know it'll be like our 17th take
and we'll do it and go great great that
was it we got it that was perfect that
was everything I'm looking for but we're
gonna do it one more time and why and
then in unison everyone on set knows the
response to that is because we love
making movies
and he did that a lot all the time
that's what you get you still talk to
him it's been a while but after the
movie came out we I did get to hang with
him do you have his number his email
yeah you do you email him occasionally I
just want to check in say hi sure it's
been a minute but yes I if I wanted to I
could reach out and and say what's up
and
uh hey did you I'd be like hey did you
see this movie you got to see it it's
awesome he well he lives in Israel now
um wow so yeah you get wife kids or kids
or a totally new life
I hear he wants to do a horror movie as
his last movie or something I did I take
take nothing you ever hear the oh here's
when you know the next what the next
Tarantino movie is going to be when he's
on set shooting it because his entire
career
oh here's what I'm gonna do next here's
what I want to do next here's what I
think I should do here's what we're
gonna do you know whatever we're gonna
do the Vega Brothers we're gonna do Kill
Bill vol 3. we're gonna do the prequel
doing glorious bastards these are all
things that he's talked about at length
and none of them have happened so here's
what I believe will happen he when we
were shooting bastards said he's going
to retire from filmmaking when he's 60.
he's gonna make 10 movies
and that's that and I was like come on
you're not gonna you're gonna walk away
and this was the phrase you use he said
I'm going to become a man of letters
what is that what does that even mean so
I'm going to be a writer say I'm a
writer I was like oh okay so the
novelization of Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood that he put out a few years
ago which I don't know if you haven't
read it it's [ __ ] great
um he's gonna do that I think for either
all of his films or he's going to start
writing the book versions of the movies
that he never had the time
to actually make so I believe we'll get
the Vega Brothers book we'll get in
glorious bastards the prequel book
Kill Bill vol 3 the book that's my
feeling this is called uh [ __ ] talking
with Sam Levine this is uh for all my
patrons top tier patrons get to ask
questions to the guests
uh this is rapid fire I know if you want
to join patreon go to patreon.com inside
of you you support and help the podcast
more than you know here we go Sophie
rapid fire
breaking in I was in the first season
that's right you were and I left can you
tell us about your time on set there
quickly uh it was a tremendous fun I got
to work with Megan Mullally who is
simply the greatest really yeah she's
magnificent I heard there was some
Nightmares on set if there were it did
not happen around me I was just a guest
star
I think two episodes right
um and getting to work with her was
wonderful and uh everyone was so nice to
me and uh Adam F Goldberg Adam F
Goldberg that was his show and uh I
think I got that job because I'd done a
short film that he'd written in 2004 and
then I got breaking in and I was like
this is great man let's work together
all the time I love it Leanne who are
some of your personal Heroes
um personal Heroes
Steve Martin uh
uh Mel Brooks
um Ken Griffey Jr
okay
Gianna H have uh having worked in the
pre-web world then seen the evolution of
the online world do you think the
fundamentals of Show Business have
changed more than just the vehicle 100
and for the record when you said pre-web
world I was like is this a Spider-Man
question
um
uh yes the the the nuts and bolts of the
industry have changed dramatically uh
since the 90s
um my God so it's so completely
different uh because you can launch a
career now from wherever you are in the
world with your phone and the internet
and huge huge acts actors musicians have
come up that way in a way that was
fundamentally impossible
for people like us to break through that
way in the 90s Justin Bieber for example
yes you're right yeah Steph F we talked
about this do you keep in touch with
anyone from Freaks and geese geekscast
yes just the one I mean I'm on good
terms with everyone like just don't keep
in touch yeah when I see them out and
about like I ran into Jason Siegel and
uh uh Solvang and you're just like dude
yeah yeah we hugged we chatted for a few
minutes but you know yeah it was it was
a lot about their lives it was nice
little Lisa what's your most prized
possession
I can't say then it's gonna get stolen
did you ever have uh Tarantino sign
anything while you're working with him
no I didn't
um but I still oh I did grab some props
would you grab
um I got some Red Apple cigarettes
really vintage Red Apple cigarettes I
got my dog tags
um if I'll be smaltzy uh my most prized
possession is now this wedding ring
you just got married I just got married
a couple months ago congratulations
thank you I I text you I was I'm so
happy for you you know I'm 50. I haven't
found that one I I am not you know I
hope one day everybody hopes dreams of
being with someone meeting someone that
they could live with for the rest of
their lives sure I know it's a it's a
Dream It's but sometimes dreams come
true
um did you feel for many years like
you are lonely or I wasn't going to find
the person I just I'm going to be single
no one gets me did you go through a lot
of that of course yeah no for sure uh
like everyone especially after a certain
age if you've had relationships you
thought were going one way and then they
didn't you know you question everything
maybe it's me what am I doing wrong
right you know if I can't figure it out
and I spent years in therapy which boy
do I recommend
um and yeah no as a young person I was a
disaster
uh and so I could never make any of
those relationships work uh and then
when I had been in therapy and I was
actively working on myself trying to be
the best version of me I could be and
things still weren't working I was like
well I don't then maybe it's just not
gonna happen
and and am I going to be okay with that
you know like I saw older friends who
had long-term marriages and then I saw
other older successful friends who were
perpetually single I was like
I don't I think I could do either of
those so maybe I'll be okay no matter
what happens right
um and uh yeah I I'm not a big fan of
the you know when you find love the
minute you stop looking that's nonsense
if you're not looking for it it ain't
gonna happen like you've seen versions
of the Tweet where it's like if it's
meant to happen the right person will
find me in my home no no you've got to
go out and do you've got to be proactive
you have to ask someone out yeah
initiative you have to risk being
rejected like we are so used to be yeah
no I went on
hundreds of dates sure as a young person
uh I would say
conservatively
300 First Dates over my dating career
that probably led to 20 second dates
overall
how long have you been married now
Rachel uh we've been married it'll be
five months five months just over five
months is it awesome magnificent
she's the greatest she's the greatest
like she's a person and we say this to
each other all the time we're like how
come I didn't know you existed until
that point of Our Lives it seems wrong
but then I'm like well if we'd have met
at any other point in our lives it might
not have worked we needed to be where we
were mentally emotionally when we met
for this to work right
um and and so the timing was great and I
tell you it's it's it's a thing that you
hope for in your head when you're a
single person looking for that and I you
find I found it and I just I'm
astonished and I fall more in love with
her every day because every day I
learned something new about her or I
interact with her in a way that just
melts my heart and uh she's beautiful
the greatest person I know what a treat
you deserve it we all deserve to be
loved and to love you know we really do
um
and I think that's for a long time I
didn't feel like I was lovable if you
know my friend said it perfectly said
logically I know that I'm lovable and
logically I know people love me
but there's a difference when you don't
feel it yes and you have to learn to
love yourself you have to learn to feel
it yes if I I am definitely a fan of
you've got to be okay with you yeah
before you can get someone else to be
okay with you 100 yeah this has been
great this has been did you enjoy it was
just two guys chatting just two guys
chatting pitting out what's oh man
what's next for you anything yeah yeah
yeah uh Minx season two Minx season two
watch HBO Max season one is on HBO Max
Minx is such a great show I have heard
Minx is a great show oh my God if you
like dong
I mean who doesn't like who doesn't like
dung do we see your dong you do not not
yet uh yeah would you show your dog uh
for what it's worth very few of the male
actors on this show who've shown their
dongs I don't believe they're real dongs
oh they're uh they're artificial dogs
yes there are plenty of real dongs but I
think you only see them uh fleetingly
right
um so I I don't know what would I show
it at this point I'm a married person
but honestly and I'm I mean this in all
sincerity nobody wants to see it why no
nobody wants to see it why not nobody
nobody wants to see me naked
but you'd be surprised I wouldn't the
people who would want it
we no they don't want to hang out with
us nobody wants to hang out with those
people
I we did get a preview of all the chest
hair though that's true oh well that you
can see uh in the show because I'm a
very low-cut open shirt so it's chest
hair go I have shown my ass in uh a few
things how do you like your ass
um it's Harry but don't you shave it I
do I shave it I've shaved it does Rachel
shave it for you now no it has not come
up yet does she ever shave your back for
you no never trims there no no the the
body hair doesn't bother her okay at
least if it does she's not said anything
uh but uh yeah no I've shown my ass I'm
I'm comfortable with it I've gotten so
much more comfortable with my body which
is the Hope as you get older you're like
it's funny I as much as I dislike it I'm
not getting a new one like this is the
boss this is it this is it this is the
hand I've been done what what is your
handle you need to follow this guy he's
obviously funny he's got great stories
he's a great Soul he goes to therapy
he's worked on himself what's your
handle I'm at Sam Levine
s-a-m-m-l-e-v-i-n-e on all the majors
watch Minx on HBO Max
um also quickly yeah Lisa Kudrow I know
she told you to get an agent and start
auditioning yeah do you still talk to
her occasionally uh every time I've seen
her we've always had a lovely
interactions yes and yes that's true
when I was uh 12 years old she saw me do
stand up at a friend's Bar Mitzvah asked
me if I was a professional I said no
she's like oh you should consider it I
was like okay how do I do that she's
like buy backstage you'll find an agent
and that's what you did and I literally
bought backstage and there was a manager
advertising are you a kid who does stand
up so I called and that's my rep who
wound up years later submitting me for
Freaks and Geeks you they're not with
him anymore uh no but I adore him right
uh uh but uh yeah no that was Sid gold
the great Sid gold the great Sid gold uh
and uh yeah so thanks Lisa thanks for
allowing me to be inside of you Sam this
has been a real treat for me the treat
has been all mine you can be inside of
me anytime you want and I will
what can I say
I like your stories it tells good
stories he does tell good stories yeah I
like yeah I like people who you know
he's been I mean he's been around
yeah that's a long time yes he's not old
I'm a one way older than him but he's
been around longer than I am yeah you
know I love his stories I love this the
Judd Apatow and the
um stories about Inglorious Bastards and
you know he's a great Storyteller and a
very funny funny naturally funny guy you
know he tells when he used to do bar
mitzvahs or whatever and like he would
do you know it's like
I get it I get it and um
I wish him the best I'm so glad he got
married and the love of his life and
they're just soul mates and
hopefully I'll find that someday Ryan
it's out there man I
yeah well thanks we're gonna do the top
tier patrons right now
um make sure you subscribe write a
review if you like this podcast and if
you missed you missed a lot of stuff in
the intro I'm not going to repeat it but
go back to the intro for some really
cool stuff that's coming up let's read
the top tier patrons let's do it
Nancy d
leas CeraVe little Lisa you Keiko Jill e
Brian H Nico P Robert D B correct Jason
du correct Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Kimberly e Mike E Eldon Supremo 99 more
Santiago M Santiago you're such a lovely
man it was so awesome hanging out with
you at the con you're gonna send me that
Lex Luthor bust right a couple of those
um
direct message me on Instagram
um I'll find it somehow when I look
through them and
um but you're you're he's such a good
guy that's all I'll say
Chad
d l w correct Leanne P correcto Janine
or Maya P Maddie s Belinda and Chris
and
m
s h h Dave H correct hi Dave how are you
Sheila G Brad
l-d Ray
H
Rey was at uh the last con she was
marvelous it was such a joy
to see her and she's pregnant and she
read some stuff at the Smallville nights
it was great to see it's great to see
the folks when I do get to see them Maya
P I think I'll be seeing I think Maddie
um you know Raj seeing all those guys in
the ligan and uh Brian it just the list
goes on but they come to the cons and I
see them and it really almost oh my God
it's like family immediately give them a
hug it's like I know them
even though we don't really know each
other I feel like that they know me
Tabitha T Tom and Liliana
h
n p c a b a yes
Talia
I don't remember M okay Betsy D Chad
D close yeah rhymes with d
B correct Dan
if I could do that every time sorry Chad
just think Dan Dan and Daniel
big Stevie W Angie Angel the angel
em you got that on your own Rhiannon C
Cory hey
okay Dev
Nixon Michelle uh okay hey yes Jeremy
see
John there's so many yeah John R B B
Brandy
D Camille s Joey M Eugene and Leah Nikki
I think Nikki comedian G Nikki Glazer
Corey
Patricia Heather
I think Nightmare on Elm Street
uh when I'm a poster
Heather the words are so small Heather
langenkamps okay l oh
Megan Megan t
Mel s Orlando
C Caroline R Christine I don't know just
think Caroline R Christine s got it next
letter in the alphabet Sarah
s correct Eric
C H Shane R Emma R Andrew M zatuichi
t77 oh crap Andreas and Oracle Karina
n
Amanda
I don't know okay Jan B Kevin e
Stephanie K Lena 82 Jarrell Billy s jam
and Jay
ADHD rocks Todd Luna R Cindy e
hi Cindy
hi Cindy Hi how are you great to see you
guys I appreciate you I love you thanks
for listening thanks for always
supporting the podcast again I know
there's millions of podcasts and a lot
of you choose this one and uh uh you
know it makes me feel really good and I
I really do see that it does help people
I'm starting to see and understand hell
wow I mean inadvertently or maybe
it's just that I try to get something
out of it that I think us humans
would want to get out of something you
know an interview like what what do you
want to get out I want some maybe
inadvertently some advice from someone I
want to find out how they get through
their troubles I want to explore you
know things I'm just curious
that's it
thanks for listening from the Hollywood
Hills in Hollywood Los Angeles
California I am Michael Rosenbaum meow
meow I'm writing dance yeah but wave to
the camera
uh so many great interviews coming up
don't miss them I met a lot of folks at
the con and we're trying I think it's
going to work out in the New Year it's
gonna be a great year but we still have
some time in this uh in this December we
call it so look take care of yourself
would you say It's A Long December Long
December
there's reason to reason to believe
maybe this year will be better than the
last
can't remember something like I don't
remember I never it's hard to sing that
song because it's different like it it's
different live every time he does not
stick to it all right I love you guys be
good to yourself and as the last
interview I just had who's coming up
which is gonna be I'm promoting now [ __ ]
I don't care it's coming out in the New
Year D Wallace the mom from ET Cujo uh
tons of [ __ ] she's got self-help books
this woman blew me away you're not gonna
believe it you're not gonna believe it
when it comes out Ryan and I said this
was the best podcast we've ever heard or
I've ever done
wait to hear it I mean it's emotional
it's fun it's Charming it's ridiculous
it's just everything a podcast should be
yeah and I'm proud of myself
and I can't wait for you to hear it so
stick around patreon stick around
everybody stick around uh she taught me
something important Ryan remember what
it is
love yourself love yourself it's the
most important thing it's hard to do
it's hard to do but you've got to learn
to love yourself before you could love
someone else love yourself I love you
see you next week